vous savez on avait tarek boudali qui
étaient là qui est un très très bon ami
fifi aussi et on a piégé de tarek
boudali tarik ben ali il a un péché
mignon sont les femmes et aussi l'humour
mais regardez j'ai un journaliste qui va
venir un journaliste non voyants qui va
venir qui va venir m'interviewer mois et
fifi et sa femme va arriver juste après
et sa femme est très très belle et très
entreprenante avec tarek regarder
pendant touche gagnée tout de regarder
que les regards de tarek budai vous
allez voir c'est tout de suite c'est
dans la grande rade sera 3 ça continue
c'est parti
[Musique]
à franchir
ouais
par michaëlle jean le cam travail
pourquoi michael en fait ça en fait moi
je travaille pour la revue lui mèche
je suis en live bénévoles en fait
lui-même qui en revue pour les
non-voyants alors tarek et là aussi il
ya suffit j'ai peut-être démarre avec
eux et après que tu le fasses avec moi
comme ça qu'on les libère
ouais moi tu des boîtes esitmant déjà
débat fissible gens fassent format dit
les blonds assez beau gosse musclé et ta
riches et pas trop d'arrêts qu'un way
tarek tarifs et bata tariq
je le vois enfin avec moustache et
cheveux frisés enfin c'est un maghrébin
un peu draps souillés enfin un truc
comme ça alors imaginez oui c'est vrai
ben oui c'est vrai que c'est pour ça que
j'avais comme ça ce cas là les questions
à l'aller question barbara c'est ma
femme a le shérif encore les jeux ses
amis alors dire bonjour
[Musique]
plaisir pouvoir alors que vous démarrez
part qu'il est une terre de peyre quand
je vais me couper parce que j'apprends
la cei au nom n'est pas maintenant je
n'ai pas le temps ça vous dérange pas
les gars vraiment vous dit investir et
en beauté il en faire sa groupie donc
oui à partir de quel âge vous avez vous
faire ce métier enfin si philippe evanno
commente tarek et moi c'est quand on
était petit déjà d'accord défection et
la même envie c'est un truc à la lettre
est très tôt et vous êtes plus 6,4 me
tenais qu'est-ce que tu skies crimes
plus je suis super content j'ai entendu
que tu allais préparer un film sur une
colonne
oui c'est vrai si vous arrêtez ces
petits missiles est ce que tu as vécu
par la suite j'ai déjà vécu en tunisie
pour barbara et moi on sait on s'est
connu à carvin c'est vrai il ya eu comme
un coup de foudre et j'ai senti sa
profondeur son âme ouais ouais ouvrir
ses bons l'embarcation s'est pas et donc
nicky larson
le casting est complet ou pas parce que
je sais pas barbara c'est une comédienne
aussi je veux pas faire un petit truc là
ça prend cinq minutes hein je fais tu
sais c'est là c'est un super mec tu
t'énerves je fais avec vous je t'aurais
vous mais juste pour les libertés ok
d'accord mais chérie ça moi je te fais
voir un petit peu comment je joue tu
veux venir là ouais tu m'as pris ce pour
quoi
non mais sérieux tu m'as pris ce portage
du tout quoi avec non mais sérieux
il faut la faire à l'école fait la cena
qui file à deux quand tu te fais l'amour
avec avec le m non je suis fier
maintenant la faire avec paraître
pourquoi pas à l'hectare ici
mais non elle n'est pas la seule équipe
non elle qu à moi on fait l'addition
matin j'arrive vraiment par harri kullas
fait tranquille ah ouais mais la
trajectoire actuelle à 6 12 ans
bah c'est pas désagréable non barbare
dont on est tous des enfants tous les
deux on se connaît depuis longtemps
embrasse moi il se passe quoi la
barbarie non non non bah non c'est juste
arak la même chose je ne sais pas
pourquoi mars atteint avec une tare est
tarie qui aujourd'hui à s'asseoir sur
ses genoux quoi ça c'est quoi ce bordel
tariq c'est quoi ce truc
c'est aussi ça soit sur lui comme je
l'aï toujours devancé par tentation
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui t'arrive s'est garni qui
est en train de faire ce chopper marque
l'essai fait des avances non mais non
mais non
qu'est-ce qui se passe je crois tout est
permis car juste après michael on oublie
tout allez merci enfin utilisent autant
à kalinka
allez ça suffit allez on arrête tout
voilà pour moi c'est vous voilà c'est
bon c'est oublier michael tu vois tu
m'as pas comment on peut continuer à les
dernières questions à paris qui relève à
tareq cheveux ça fait quoi d'être piégés
par la nostra sera
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mauvais ça c'est une caméra café qui a
marché que sur les regards tarek vous
donner